the idea is to take a single photograph
or the face and as outputs we get a 3d
model in volumetric form where do you
start doing something like that this
kind of thing as we can be more common
now with CNN's you can give them a
problem and just let them try and solve
it
this is convolutional neural networks
right yeah that's right so the idea is
that so as the image comes in we apply
some filters the values of these filters
are learnt through gradient descent and
Mike has a video talking about I think
that yeah so of ab8 months and we
decided it would be quite fun if we
release a kind of an online
demonstration mainly so people didn't
have to run the code on their own
computer because you have to install all
sorts of dependencies and you need a GPU
and yeah this is a much easier way you
can just upload a photograph and as an
app when you get a 3d mesh which you can
rotate and play with this is the object
which you can download and view in mesh
lab so if I also disabled the colors
this is a actual that the object without
without any texturing implies the actual
mesh which comes out of the network is
slightly higher resolution than this but
because of demand we have to kind of
compress it a bit in general it seems to
capture things like the mouth and the
nose yeah you can try and compare yeah
so it's running on one of the GPU
machines that we have in the group and I
think of a moment's processing maybe 80
photographs per well at the time maybe
3,000 per hour this is the photograph of
your face and we have I'm gonna draw a
magic box for now and I'll try and fill
it in in a bit and so everything is
coming this direction and as output we
produce a cubes and this is a 3d volumes
made up of much smaller cubes and in
each one of these cubes the network
progresses a value of 0 or 1 and then we
use a growth and called marching cubes
which takes the surface of all of these
ones and simply send that back to the
website and we use that framework 3GS
to to render it so the magic box turns
the simple image somehow into this 3d
shape and then you basically color it in
with the photograph yeah so the
texturing at the moment is is
ridiculously simple so if you upload a
side profile it will actually take the
texture from from the front of your face
all on the back and you might also
notice some distortion around the sides
where it's actually included the
background
beam up behind the face but the problem
was not to try and improve texturing it
was to try and encouraging him improve
the quality of the 3d reconstruction
it has good good performance and have
you taken some of these 3d volumes and
compared them to actual 3d scans just to
see how close they are
or is it will be by eye we did a lot of
testing and calculating of error which
is probably actually one of the most
challenging problems in doing this work
the ground tree that we have doesn't
have any details you know it doesn't
show wrinkles or spots but the fit is
very good to the face so it should you
know try and match the shape of the face
the magic question which is what's going
on in the box so inside we have an
architecture which actually looks like
an hourglass it's called the sniper
glass so here we have the first part of
the hourglass and we have it up sampling
again and then we have a secondary glass
in here the image comes in the spatial
resolution as it passes through the
convolutional neural network is getting
smaller until we have something maybe a
10 pixels by 10 pixels so not the
original resolution which is closer to
200 by 200 we then up sample it and
while we're up sampling it we actually
have smaller our glass networks which
are working at larger resolutions so
these come from an earlier point in the
network so as this is being up sampled
we're combining the result from these
smaller cnn's
this increases the the resolution around
the side of the face for example so you
have more detail
otherwise you just get a blurry very old
basically
yes so as you have these largest CNN's
inside these an increase the global
context so you know the eyes are in the
right place and the mouth is below the
eyes for example this thing goes for
another start our glass Network which is
identical so it also has these smaller
our glass networks and as output we just
take the 3d volume the outlets there is
taking a 2d image so these smaller but
higher resolution our glasses at the
sides are they making the size how does
it extrapolate it yes so it can actually
be thought of as a segmentation problem
so there's a lot of work on using
communal networks for segmentation so if
you take a single image you'll it will
give you a mask of pixels and you give
each pixel a number with it being like a
person or a dog for example instead of
regressing a single class per channel as
output so if you if you're segmenting
dogs and humans you'd have two channels
in this case we regress 200 channels but
they're all the same class they're all
the human face so anytime that you have
a set of zeros you know that it's part
of the face if you imagine a cube drawn
around my face because you know your
face is now inside a cube yeah the
slices inside of cube and if you chopped
my face up into smaller slices you would
see a set of ones in any place that it
is so on the front you just see a few
ones on the tip of my nose as you get
towards my ears you'll see kind of you
know just ears around oh I know it'll
shake like that I suppose it's working
out what features the 2d image is off
and then it's putting those in the right
place in 3d space is that right exactly
yeah so before we we protest the image
we first move the face so it's in the
same sort of spatial dimension as the
the cube that we output so the output of
the 3d cube should be spatially aligned
perfectly with the face which is why
when you see on the website the actual
volume is perfectly aligned if you have
a slight rotation to your face the the
mesh will also be aligned with with that
one thing I noticed was how was yeah so
the training set doesn't contain any
anyhow
it's it's just the 3d shape of the face
and when we were producing the dataset
that we train from we actually didn't
bother with the back of the head it
would be quite nice to have have the
back of the head as well the problem is
that since it is a volumetric problem we
actually have to produce these volumes
which means checking the voxels there
inside the mesh or not and that can be
quite time-consuming we have some
statistics which I've been watching
continuously case on link crashes so in
the back end we have six queues and at
the moment there are 67 images waiting
and across those keys you can see that
we've had one hundred and eighty one
thousand photographs that loaded most of
those have been since the 12th of
September and today I think is the 19th
yep
so just in the past minute we've had 70
which have been uploaded so that's why I
feel sorry or bad for the technical
services at the moment there's so much
traffic I don't want to just switch it
off and I would like it to be available
for other researchers who want to try
and look at our work we'll see what
happens but I hope that we can keep it
running so the reason why it doesn't
work on the online demonstration when
you use a side pose is because the face
detector we're using doesn't doesn't
recognize these faces so instead of
producing a horrible results we would
rather just image and lots of features
going on way back so these are my
different convolutions of convolutions
of convolutions of convolution